Here I am on Stanford University where I
discovered these angels oh I feel as if
I never and what is oh how are you going
oh lady Himiko welcome like a high oh
yes I'm zakon integra oh man oh yeah so
good my gosh oh you did oh man you can't
dance haha so it's always lovely to be
at a university center of learning are
you students here no but I graduated
already okay and it makes you feel good
people are studying stuff and you're
having your friends your maidens of
honor some of you right yes all your
friends are getting married yeah on a
beautiful day what a wonderful occasion
ok so here i am at Stanford and you know
I always find it very exhilarating to be
at a university it's a Center where
people aren't doing nasty things most of
time they're learning or doing research
there are inefficiencies I'm not sure
there's always the value there given the
cost of universities whether the student
pays that are the state pays it but
there's something there that that is
uplifting it's it's it's a bit like a
church it makes you humble in a way
accumulation of learning over centuries
I enjoy it now heading off to the
bookstore to see what sort of language
books they might have I'm always a
sucker for language books here i am in
the stanford bookstore and i must say
i'm just amazed at the price books
textbooks so you know if you wanted to
do for example there's modern chinese
took a picture of a textbook $62 and the
workbook is another thirty dollars
that's just for one be don't know how
many sections that are in it but some of
the other ones the russian and the
italian or even more expensive it's just
amazing in some of these books I mean
you look inside them I mean
if you can see it comics and stuff like
that I guess that's and then of course
the usual long vocabulary lists and
stuff I must say this just turns me off
entirely but they must know what they're
doing so there's something about instead
of Spanish the garden inspired no done
by the Arabs and I just really like the
wonderful garden in Spain some of the
monasteries or we stayed up para doors
and so this I guess kind of spanish
colonial architecture here captures this
feeling of Spanish maybe and of us Ian
culture alright nice very nice
especially on a day like this love it